I use that kind of language like feet
held to the mouths flames and then I
know that you talked a lot about pullers
don't you think that's adding to the
polarisation like you're talking about
Mao and you're invoking this idea of
fire serious communism isn't that a
little bit severe I don't think it's any
more severe than starting with the
assumption that I'm part of the
alt-right hey there my Kluber and/or
youtuber we are introducing a new
segment today long-form interview called
devil's advocate well we'll bring on the
four most conservative thinkers critical
thinkers and try to present both points
of view I think it was my friend Owen
who actually said if you cannot argue
your ideological opposition's point of
view as effectively as they can you have
no business holding your own position so
the purpose of this format is to argue
the left's the progressive left's
position more effectively than they do
and hopefully equip you in case you will
encounter these these arguments these
lines of questioning these specific
patterns of attack that you see from the
left so I warn you you might get mad you
might get frustrated you might want to
beat up Skylar I know that I did these
do not represent my views at all or the
views of anybody at loud or with crowd
or unless I don't know about it enjoy
devil's advocate with dr. Jordan
Peterson all right I'm your host
Scarlett Urton I was a segment where we
take on the biggest right-wing
personalities on the web out there sort
of in the cultural sphere and challenge
them hold their feet to the fire to see
if their ideas hold water and our next
guest is a very popular so very you know
noted fascist super popular Internet
personality you can take his personality
quiz I guess itself authoring calm his
book is 12 you 12 rules for life is
available at places
Jordan Peterson thanks for being on the
show sir thanks for the invitation
there's Skyler yes so let me allow you
to sort of establish with people who
aren't necessarily familiar you've made
it your main gold
an advocate of free speech particularly
speaking out against restrictions
thereof I know it started you sort of
Roseanne notoriety with Bill c16 in
Canada
tell us your in your own words why
freedom of speech is so important and
why you took your stand okay well first
of all I don't think that that's what I
put myself forward in in the main okay
I'm not very interesting interested in
the relationship between meaning and
responsibility okay and so I think that
my books and my lectures are mostly
devoted towards that I see free speech
as necessary because it's part of the
process by which the left and the right
continue in an ongoing dialogue about
how society should both maintained and
updated structures and that any attempts
to interfere without our dangerous to
both necessary wings let's say okay and
in Canada there was a bill passed a year
ago in May bill C 16 which purported to
do nothing but extend charter rights and
certain protections under the Criminal
Code to transgender people and but I
that isn't how I looked at the
legislation I thought it was a piece of
compelled speech the justifications for
doing that we're very thin well okay let
me let me ask you that so first first
off okay
meaning responsibility where they
intersect but freedom of speech is a big
component to that right and that's why
you talk about it well it's a
responsibility to speak properly and it
shouldn't be something that the
government should interfere with the
government interferes with that at its
peril whether it happens to be left or
right leading why I want to make sure I
wasn't you know cuz you made it sound
like I was misrepresenting you but it
sounds like no that's that's that it was
a big part of it so the thing of its
piece bill c16 right you say that I've
read through the bill I've not seen
anything that specifically relates to
compelled language you often use that
word compulsion of language I don't see
it in there that's because it was a
particularly treacherous piece of
legislation and most of what was
reprehensible about it was hidden in the
surrounding documentation mostly on the
Ontario Human Rights Commission website
the
government announced publicly before
they took the link down that the bill
would be interpreted in light of the
documentation on the Ontario Human
Rights Commission which clearly made it
grounds for grounds for civil action at
least and perhaps criminal action to
misgender someone despite the lack of
any norms currently operating with
regards to the use of gender pronouns
for example and it also instantiated a
social constructionist view of gender
into Canadian law which I thought was
equally reprehensible given that the
scientific evidence is overwhelming that
a substantial part of gender differences
in biology and personality and
temperament are biologically influenced
if not determined right and I know then
we can get into sort of this biological
determinism I know it's really popular
with the alt-right and that's fear but
it sounds to me like what you just said
before we move on to more Fruma speech
and the meat of some of your other
topics you discuss it sounds to me like
you're talking about a potential
interpretation of the law provincially
but that's not what the law said and
considering that's like the catalyst for
you here's this rock star on the right
do you think that's that's a little
important I don't think that there would
have been inclusions within the law of
changes to the Criminal Code if the
intent wasn't much broader and that you
know the law was only about a paragraph
long and so the surrounding
documentation is of crucial importance
and if the federal government was
playing straight with regards to the
origin of the law and how was it going
to be interpreted they wouldn't have
taken down the link that had made the
claim quite straightforwardly that it
was going to be interpreted in light of
the Ontario Human Rights Commission's
already extent policies but you
surrounded similar legislation at the
provincial level besides it played out
exactly the way I thought it would play
out for example at Wilfred Laurier
University where a teaching assistant
was held to the had her feet held to the
Maoist flames for daring to show a video
expressing my views to a communications
class now you use that kind of language
like feet held to the Maoist flames and
then I know that you talked a lot about
polarize
don't you think that's adding to the
polarisation like you're talking about
Mao and you're invoking this idea of
fire serious communism is not a little
bits of
I don't think it's any more severe than
starting with the assumption that I'm
part of the alt-right which is a real
white supremacist organization and an an
identity politics group rightly all
right I don't say you reporter the old
one yeah you did actually you could just
rewind the tape no I mentioned that it
was popular in all right circles and you
happen to be popular in all the right
circles I happen to popular at
universities and they show you know I'm
not responsible for what those
professors say I'm just saying it's your
views would you disagree happen to
coincide with the views of a lot of the
alt-right yeah I would disagree I don't
think they agree with the alt-right at
all in fact I have some very pronounced
enemies on the alt-right and they've
come out and said exactly that because
I've said in multiple public appearances
that I'm no fan of collectivists I don't
really care if they're on the left or on
the right it's equally reprehensible as
far as I'm concerned yeah well it's just
two different ways of playing identity
politics there's a left-wing way in a
right-wing way and I'm not a favor in
favor of either of them yeah so I think
any attempt whatsoever to associate me
with the alt-right regardless of whether
you know you have an opinion that I have
followers there is merely an attempt to
shore oh great what I'm saying by
association well I don't I don't listen
that's not what I'm trying as much it is
popular these are popular and alright
circle what they do disagree what's your
evidence no you're right they do
disagree with you and largely because
you're you know Canadian that's a bit
there's a split there with American
alright and in Canada but let me go back
to what you were just talking about here
sort of you mentioned biology now let's
say that we I agree with you right
biology and it's a big determining
factor in in gender let's for the sake
of argument like gender and sex are the
same thing I'm assuming obviously
haven't really ain't familiarize
yourself with Simone de Beauvoir Butler
but that's cool so you're from a well
yeah okay familiar enough and that's
dangerous yeah well that's the danger
with a lot of people they're only
familiar enough but let's assume that
it's as correct okay and that biology
determines gender I don't think we would
disagree that transgenders have been the
victim of hate crimes and a
disproportionate rate and this is the
complication that I think a lot of a lot
of right-wingers miss they see it they
they're very reductive you know
permitting absolute freedom of speech it
silences other people's free speech
because
allows people to vote bully victims into
silence and then you have freedom of
speech if it's blanket it actually
reduces the totality of free speech
because of minorities who are afraid to
speak out is that a problem that you
agree with well there's no doubt that
speech can be misused and commonly is
the question isn't that isn't the issue
the issue is who's going to regulate it
and the the answer to that is minimal
regulation because it's such a
fundamental part of the ability to think
and orient yourself in the world and so
it's perfectly reasonable to point out
that free speech can be abused and has
been in the past but then the the Devils
in the details say well it's it's being
used to oppress minorities while also to
free them we might point out the left
wing was a tremendous advocate for free
speech right up until I would say five
or six years ago partly because people
who are oppressed need free speech above
all else to make their claims heard I
mean that's always been how it's playing
out but it's not how it's playing out
for five years I don't know what the
hell that has to do on the broader
broader scheme of things you can be sure
that any restrictions that the Left
manages to put on on free speech will
immediately be co-opted by the right so
it's an extraordinarily foolish game and
then that's and there's an issue that's
even deeper than that which is well
we've already agreed that speech can be
let's say harsh and divisive and
oppressive all of those things whose
gonna regulate it who's whose hands are
you gonna put that power in well here's
the thing I think you do this a lot in
people people on the right just a lot
where they sort of acts like this
government is as far off entity who
makes these decisions in Washington DC
listen it's us right we're word
democracy here in the United States
people vote in their representatives so
the government is us I pay my taxes I
get water that comes from my tap the
same speed as I get access to the
freeways does anyone else we do agree
when we live in a society that a
government has a certain control I mean
we don't complain about other
regulations and this is where I think we
complain about any regulation that
transgresses constitutional rights and
the right to free speech is probably the
primary right
least in the u.s. okay it's all right on
which the entire government edifice is
built and to say that you can elect
elect representatives who are going to
regulate free speech ignores the fact
completely that you don't have an
absolute democracy of a constitutional
democracy all these same rights are in
charge of what can be they're in charge
of what can be said as far as libel laws
with the press so we do have a freedom
of the press but we do have actual libel
laws there are regulations on firearms
right you don't think that you should be
able to go off and own a tank so again
these are constitutional amendments of
liable laws that go discussed those
would fall under freedom of the press
the First Amendment with freedom of
speech why I think the restrictions that
are placed on free speech are already
plenty sufficient and to extend to any
degrees is a very big mistake and
besides there's a huge difference with
regards to compelled speech I should
point out that the your American Supreme
Court the 1940s made compelled speech
unconstitutional so Canada passed a law
that would be clearly unconstitutional
in the United States it was also a law
passed at the federal and provincial
level because it compelled speech that
had absolutely no precedent in English
common law because there's a difference
between saying what people can't say
so that's libel and saying what they
have to say which is compelled speech
and the Supreme Court said very
explicitly in the United States that it
was a mistake
both both on the part of restricting the
speaker and restricting the listener to
compel people to utter words with which
they did not agree now there's certain
exceptions for commercial law but there
are no exceptions in non-commercial
speech and so to bring in libel law and
that sort of thing is complete red
herring well I want to be sure because
you just mentioned red herring Harriet
you say so you're I want to make clear I
understand your problem is with
compelled speech then correct not saying
what you can't say about forcing people
what as to what they absolutely no fan
whatsoever of hate speech legislation
but that's which is which is I suppose
the logical extension of laws attempting
to restrict what you can't say right so
I think hate speech laws are dreadful
and I think they're being misused all
the time and that we've only seen the
beginning of that but the issue of
compelled speech is worse than the issue
of regulating hate speech because it it
requires people to utter words that they
did not formulate and may not believe so
it violates freedom of
conscience it violates the
responsibilities that each individual
has to only say things they believe to
be true and representative of their
viewpoint it interferes with their
ability to think and communicate and it
makes them terrified of of potential
potentially terrified of government and
other organizational intervention people
are terrified right now because the
First Amendment was written long before
social media and Facebook and so now the
speech is very invasive a used tool to
turn it off now you can't we'll come
back to that because I know we have a
lot of topics to get into and you know
as in your words you're not just now to
get a free speech with the sort of we're
meaning intersects with responsibilities
you just brought up hate speech laws so
I think it's a good transition that
Jordan do you support equality it's a
that's a trick it's a trick questions
how about you specify it a little bit
more clearly before I answer that okay
do you support equality of race gender
sexual orientation same same objection
applies define equality the quality of
opportunity for sure the quality
fragment at least again it's it's in
sufficiently defined question okay
quality treatment all right quality
opportunity for sure I think that any
any bureaucratic structure that's set up
that doesn't allow each person to be
assessed on the basis of their merits in
relationship to a particular function
like a job yeah is it is a big mistake
for everyone involved including the
individuals that are unreasonably
discriminated against so sounds like it
sounds like a long way around to say to
say no let me ask you this you've spoken
out against the problem of free speech
in regards to speakers specifically on
campus universities people being
censored on social media let me don't
see that is it's not even a question
like of speakers for example on campus
is it a question of free speech at all
is I'm not just a private entity
refusing to serve an individual whose
message they don't agree with not
hosting them well it's certainly not the
case in Canada because the universities
are public and it's all that's also the
case in many universities in the United
States so and then with regards to the
private and entities I suppose it
depends on why they're doing it and
under what pressure they are operating I
mean a typical trick now is to
is to to charge the the the individuals
who are coming to campus outrageous
security fees to prevent them from being
able to speak so there's plenty of what
would you call it there's there's plenty
of lack of fair play at work in those
sorts of situations so your and I think
universities above all should should be
cautious about restricting who's allowed
to speak on campus for ideological
reasons oh I agree I think they should
be super careful so I want to make sure
that you're so you only have a problem
not with private universities but public
university I didn't say I didn't have a
problem with private universities it's
clearly it's clearly the problem with
public universities doing it with
private universities there is that
additional element that you just
described okay so would you compel
public universities to host speakers I
disagree with define compel force them
to host speakers they disagree with I
would encourage them to leave speakers
alone if student organizations invite
them onto campus then the university
should do what it can to keep ideology
out of the picture and to allow them to
speak right so public university is
saying OK for us Jordan Peterson is
aligned because you know because of his
misgendering of people and his
anti-trans sort of speak or some of his
his whatever you want to use a
homophobic anti left-wing rhetoric and
then another universal that's a typical
example of exactly why it's very
dangerous to let ideologues determine
where the free speech line is drawn
because you know in formulating that
question you used a whole string of
unwarranted epithets that you drew from
very badly conducted press interviews to
characterize my viewpoints and so just
by formulating the question the way you
did you indicated how terribly dangerous
it is to allow Committees of video logs
to determine who should be able to allow
you should be allowed to speak and on
what topic well let me ask you this then
um first off you're you're saying you
don't see yourself as having spoken any
anti-transgender rhetoric at all no
really there's nothing to do with
transgender it has nothing to do with
transgender individuals it
to do with compelled speech okay started
it happened to involve a bill that
involved transgender people was Maura
and I would say an accident that was the
okay that was the issue that brought
this to rise so so so you'll use the Jen
people's preferred pronouns then oh I
haven't and it would depend on how I was
asked it would depend on which pronouns
and it would depend on what I thought
their motivation for requiring them was
and it would depend on whether they
demanded it and all of that so at the
moment I I'm very disinclined to do it
because now I have to do it I'm legally
compelled to do it in Canada and that's
enough reason for me to say no well it
sounds to me like that you said that you
gave a lot of depends for someone who
believes yeah that's for sure
and you don't have it right you don't
have the right to determine how I dress
you well you don't have the right to
deny their reality to denied who they
are how they identify why it so they say
there's no I deny people's reality all
the time by disagreeing with them so and
they do the same to me and you have
every right to deny someone's reality
that's that's the whole basis of your
ability to think independently is that
you get to define reality one way and
other people get to define it another
way and then hopefully you negotiate a
shared reality that you can both live in
peacefully well that's a specious
argument well no that's my point is
because for someone who does talk about
moral absolutism to some degree you know
in this case there are a lot of depends
and for example if a black guy said hey
I'm black you can just say no you're not
and then can you use racial epithets or
what he considers racial epithets I mean
this it's because people in trance I can
whether I should or not is a different
issue and whether or not it should be
illegal is a completely different issue
so whether I can whether same thing no
it's not it's going to go out and if a
black guy repeat if you call him the
n-word that's really it's harassment if
you continually do it's not ego in the
United States okay
agree to disagree on that one because
there's no disagreeing about it's not
illegal I'll go see how that works if
you go on down to Spanish Harlem
just be sure to upload it with a go
probably didn't say that you should do
it and I did but I did say that it was
legal well yeah I know and that's that's
that's kind of this debate and switch
that you pull Jordan quite a bit is you
say well I didn't say it was look I
didn't say was right what do you think
is right let me ask you this let me ask
the ladies around what do you think is
right as far as how to gender somebody
who identifies who has been abused has
been the victim of hate crimes their
whole life and wants to be referred to
by their specific pronouns what do you
think is right I think that your attempt
to use hypothetical compassion for
someone hypothetically oppressed is an
appalling way to defend a compelled
speech law no that's what I think yeah
because because it puts think about what
that does it puts you completely in the
driver's seat doesn't it you get sit
there and think well I'm a compassionate
wonderful person with me essential me
and of a saint and this person who's
addressing me is obviously entirely
corrupt because they don't have the same
moral compassion for the oppressed that
I do it's like I'm not even going to
engage in that it's it's an appalling
way of arguing what makes you think that
you're so compassionate what makes you
think that you've got all the right on
your side because I'm so you don't think
there's anything dangerous about the
government attempting to produce
compelled speech legislation on the back
of hypothetical compassion you can't see
any way that would go wrong well I'll
talk about that you're not thinking you
just talking many times in the past and
you're using your your mask of
compassion and care for the oppressed to
justify whatever actions you want to
undertake alright listen I let you go
here you talking paragraphs around
circles now you're misrepresenting me I
didn't say that at all I didn't say it I
don't see any problems with it I think
I'm the only one in this you haven't
pointed out any problems with it so far
I'm also I'm also the only one doesn't
condemned compassion in any way shape or
form and I look passion needs to be
condemned in many many ways because
people use it as an unthinking marker
for moral virtue and that's not that all
I understand that it can be subjectively
condemned but I'm saying there's one of
us here who has advocated it as a virtue
and I think you'd do well to include
that in your rhetoric this is the idea
that compassion is a virtue and I don't
think that it should be arbitrary I'm
talking about people with to Google
again the government is these are
elected officials and we elect the most
qualified people for the job
you cannot elect someone who's the most
qualified for the job and then decide
that they don't have the authority that
you've granted them that's what a
constitution is for that is what yes you
absolutely can say Constitution puts
limits on the on the power of the
elected representatives and you
hardly that's to protect the rights of
minorities and one of the most
fundamental rights that minorities have
is the right to free speech it's
absolutely unbelievable that the left
who hypothetically are standing up for
the for the rights of the oppressed are
are daring to challenge the supremacy of
free speech because it's been the
fundamental weapon that people who are
dispossessed have used against power
structures since since the beginning of
the write itself so it's unbelievably
short-sighted and if you think that the
restrictions on free speech that are
being put in place by the left won't be
misused by the right then you're not
thinking at all you know you keep saying
the Constitution's change some people
think that income tax is
unconstitutional do you think income tax
is unconstitutional if to completely do
it with income tax because we have
amendments to deal with that the point
is it's a living breathing document
right and the people who have been given
granted that's not living and breathing
as much as the radicals who wish to
transform it according to their ideology
think it is so and you mess with
constitutional amendments at your peril
okay so the whole idea here that the
fundamental what would you call it the
fundamental assumption of this whole
line of questioning is that you're
particularly illogical stance puts you
firmly on the side of the dispossessed
and that makes you admirable and correct
and first of all I don't buy the
argument that you're on the side of the
dispossessed merely because you say you
do the fact that you're strong
limitations just the fact that you're
arguing for limitations on free speech
indicates to me that you're no friend
whatsoever of people who are truly
dispossessed so but those people to
those people disagree with you more than
me I mean how many how many minorities
really are lining up for Jordan Peterson
right well I mean that's a rhetorical
question and there's plenty of people
who are so-called minorities that are
coming to my talks for example you don't
have any hard data on that so okay so
something like nice at ninety percent
over ninety percent of black Americans
vote Democrat it's not even close Latino
Americans Asian Americans it's it's not
even close it's 80 or above for every
single demographic so the point is right
I don't want to speak for minorities and
I know you don't want speak for
minorities but they agree with my stance
a lot more that's how they vote so it's
clear they don't have a problem with a
guy like me and I'm not saying that I'm
inherently right that that all I'm
trying to point out is that I think
maybe you're not consistent on freedom
of speech
let me okay let's ask this this just
happened this week facebook spotify
Apple YouTube right they all banned the
Infowars channel so let me ask you do
you think that's a good thing or that's
a bad no I think it's a catastrophe okay
so what's your what's your solution do
you believe Facebook or YouTube should
be forced to provide a platform for
speech that they detest no I don't think
they should be forced I think that
they're I think that they've they've bit
off far more than they'll be able to
chew because um because now they've
decided well now they've decided that
there are ethically responsible for the
content on their platforms so good luck
with that decision because they have an
awful lot of content and drawing the
lines is going to be extraordinarily
difficult thing to do so basically the
way that these companies were set up to
begin with is that people could post
content and then other people could
watch it and basically decide by their
viewing they could value the content by
their proclivity to view hmm and now
they've decided as a consequence of this
decision that they're going to be in the
business of arbitrarily determining what
should and shouldn't be presented for
public viewing and they'll never run out
of decisions to make you know lots of
people were watching Alex Jones didn't
agree with them
they were just keeping an eye on him so
I watched Alex Jones from time to time
because I wanted to see what the radical
conspiratorial right-wing was up to
right you know that's not possible now
they're driven underground way to come
on tracks with a browser history I
appreciate it let me ask you this
there's going to be all sorts of lines
that they have to decide now so they're
going to take out Paul Joseph Watson
next Lauren southern I mean exactly okay
so if it's against their Terms of
Service isn't it within their domain to
revoke the channel what's the solution
for cities I didn't say they couldn't do
it I said it was a bad idea okay so
you're not same thing okay so you don't
have a think it's good well I think I
think that they've I really do believe
and I'm sad about this I do believe that
they've bitten off more than they can
chew and that it's going to be it's it's
it's one small it's a it's a warning
sign with regards to these media
conglomerates that are attempting to
produce large-scale public discourse
because now they've taken on they've
taken the role of
so onto themselves and they'll find it
that's a never-ending rule that produces
endless trouble they've got themselves
into endless trouble as far as I'm
concerned and for as it from a
perspective of a clinical psychologist I
would also say the worst thing you can
do to someone who's paranoid the most
ill-advised thing you can do to someone
who's paranoid is persecute them so now
that I mean Alex Jones is always talking
about the little I know about him he's
always talking about conspiracies of one
form or another and now what has all the
appearance of a conspiracy between four
or five very large media conglomerates
is aimed squarely at him so all the
people who are watching him who are
conspiracy minded and somewhat paranoid
are going to think well Jones must be on
to something because otherwise these big
conglomerates wouldn't have clamped down
on him now it's a very very bad idea and
millions of people watch him so these
are people who these are people who
thought that Podesta had an unheard sex
ring and a pizza parlor so I don't
really think that this is necessarily
the straw that broke the camel's back
it sounds to me so I want to make sure
that clarify are you not amongst the
people who believe that these big
platforms like YouTube Facebook should
be treated like public utilities because
there are a lot of right-wingers who do
believe that like phones yeah I think
they should be treated as public
utilities because otherwise they can't
exist because there's no possible way
that these corporations can handle
monitoring that their content there's
too much content so they'll read they'll
run out of manpower to make the
decisions I mean what okay so Alex Jones
is now being banned what do you think
about people who interviewed Alex Jones
should they be banned
that would include Jill Rogen for
example because he interviewed Alex
Jones you know so should we ban him well
if not why not
so you think that Facebook YouTube
Google these companies that you know
basically start up in garages these tech
startups invest millions of dollars and
they grow to become successful and then
you support the government stepping in
in an authoritarian fashion and telling
them who they have to allow in their
platforms I didn't say the government
should step in I said that they made a
mistake by deciding to act as censors
and that they'll pay for it I didn't say
anything about anybody stepping in and
changing it I said it was a mistake well
if they're to be treated like public
utilities and there would be the
government stepping in and because right
now they're not well if they were to be
treated
utilities that would be a transformation
in the way they were regulated so that
really doesn't have anything to do
specifically with the alex jones issue
supporter you would support it and
that's let's first the question because
i'm the one having to come up with all
the complex answers alright so how would
you propose that these complex
corporations decide which content is
acceptable
exactly now would you present i don't
think there does need to be a proposal i
mean i think this is where actually i
would be on your side let the free
market decide and the free market is
youtube and facebook and if they don't
want to how's content i don't think they
should be forced to host content i don't
think they should be compelled to host
content well obviously they shouldn't be
that that's not the issue the issue is
how are they going to go about making
the decisions and how are we going to be
sure that that won't go dreadfully wrong
I mean obviously it's the case that
censorship can go wrong you certainly
see that in places like China once you
start with censorship how do you know
how do you have any idea how are you
gonna put proper boundaries around it
and decide who's acceptable you're
they're gonna let your listeners decide
that or you're gonna decide it and then
you're gonna find out that you've taken
on a huge weight of decision making that
you can't handle well maybe I'm wrong
maybe that won't happen but it's certain
certainly I would be very loath to
decide what needs to be censored because
the number of decisions I'd have to make
would multiply beyond end well I'm not
saying that any specific individuals I'm
saying let the free market decide if
people don't want Alex Jones on YouTube
then YouTube doesn't have to provide it
if people watching YouTube do I already
agreed that YouTube doesn't have to
provide it I said it was a mistake to
engage in censorship sure just because
people are allowed to do something
doesn't mean it isn't a mistake upon
occasion so I'm not asking for
government regulation and the idea that
transforming these corporations into
something approximating utilities would
be a form of regulation is really a and
what would you say it's an informed way
of posing the question it's a matter of
classification do you think that Alex
Jones should be able to use a phone why
do you think Alex Jones to be able use a
phone as long as he pays for it
as long as the phone company wants to
offer him their services right so the
phone company offers everyone equal
access to the services regardless of
content and I presume you Dobb jecht if
the phone service started to decide that
conversation shouldn't be allowed to
occur
and so it you can make a reasonable
argument that these large-scale media
distribution companies play the same
role but on a larger scale it's not
necessarily the case that it's an
argument without flaw but it's a
reasonable argument and but I don't
think that there's any real alternative
I don't see how companies like Facebook
and YouTube can possibly police their
content without producing far more
trouble than they'll save that's the
issue well I'm not so much just
concerned about them policing the
content what I'm concerned what's is
let's say we do the so the public
utilities sort of option right what I'm
concerned with is the free market will
be able to provide alternatives you know
Alex Jones can go there if we believe if
we're consistent we believe in freedom
of speech in the freedom of market as it
applies thereof we should be free to
accept we should believe follow this
down the logical trail that there will
be an alternative platform for all yeah
yes there probably will be and that's
also why I think it was a mistake for
these companies to engage in the
censorship because I think that they're
signing their own death warrant by doing
so it'll probably take 10 years to
unfold but it's a big mistake and so
that is what will happen is because
people will stop trusting YouTube and
Facebook and so forth to provide
uncensored access to content and as a
consequence other forms of information
distribution will emerge so it's that's
why I thought it was a bad decision from
corporate perspective okay they had
every right to make it but I think it's
bad decision if I were to if I were to
walk into your house okay if I were to
walk into your house right now and just
and harass you and and call you all
sorts of names and get right up in your
face and not leave after you've asked me
to leave and continue harassing you
without any without any any refuge for
you would you think that that is a crime
for me to do that I don't know why
you're asking the question so let me
tell you so now again this is why we
talk about the Constitution in guns now
I have fully automatic air 15's and
things change right times change we need
to adapt and we've both agreed on that
to some extent now online people like
Alex Jones they have the ability to
invade your house digitally continually
and harass and berate always shut off
not necessarily that's the thing you
can't you can't shut off everything you
can't block people you can't mute
people on every platform then they have
your email on YouTube you you know it
shows up in your suggested feed the
point is especially argument you can
just shut the whole thing off if you
want so it's a silly argument it's not
like someone invading your house so
because you can shut it off at any time
okay that's just not that's just not
going anywhere that argument or what if
someone has a computer in their house
then if they have a computer now son it
means that someone can invade their
their house that way digitally there's
there's no way to find a space away from
me particularly people like Alex Jones
most egregious offenders right who
spread conspiracies and effectively like
lead to daxing of people I mean that's a
lot of this the thing is to its again
again the the question is more
fundamental let's assume that it's a bad
idea for poorly supported conspiracy
theories to be formulated and
distributed now let's assume that yeah
fine well we don't need to put it in air
quotes we could probably both assume it
the question is what should you do with
people who are doing that and the one
answer is well do what you can to
silence them and drive them underground
the other is let them talk and let
people make up their own minds and my
sense is and is that people are wise
enough to listen to people of that sort
and decide that that's too extreme now
not everyone because conspiracy
theorists can find followers among
people who are disagreeable in somewhat
paranoid but it's best for everyone
including the conspiracy theorists
themselves that those things are aired
in public discussion because it helps
keep people saying you know like I've
known people who are a little bit
disagree yeah but that's because you
don't know what you're talking about
okay no one correct listen there are
more Americans who believe in angels
than in climate change the top shows
they're Kardashians look at what's on
television I don't believe that the
American public that anyone should be
granted autonomy issue yeah there should
be why they treat you should treat them
wise enough I'm saying I don't think
they're wise enough and that's why
they're wise enough compared to the
alternatives okay you know your system
in the United States was never set up
under the presumption that the people
were wise it was set up under the
presumption that the people regardless
of their wisdom had the right to
self-determination and even more
importantly that although the people
themselves might not always be wise
there
isn't a better source of authority than
the people themselves so that no matter
how corrupt and foolish the people
happen to be whatever systems you put in
place to supplant them will be worse and
so I think and and you might not believe
that but that's fine but that is the
founding principle at least I don't
believe that's fine you know I don't
believe it I don't believe that I don't
believe that Alex Jones and anyone with
a Facebook page is for example as
qualified and and as safe for the
American public as Walter Cronkite or
people in the Senate and House who are
qualified to make these determinations I
don't that's just a disagreement but all
that people you know disagreement it's
actually a disagreement about the
fundamental structure of the entire
political system because you think that
it's possible to produce banks of
experts of one sort or another who can
supplant the fundamental will of the
people and I don't think I think that
that's a very bad idea and I think that
history shows that that's a bad idea at
least with democracy itself tends to be
self-correcting so if people make
egregious errors they correct them in
the next election well okay so sorry I
want to give you the quote so again that
is self authoring com if you want to
take your quiz and the book twelve rules
for life is available at places
so let me final question do you or is
ever concern you that you might be on
the wrong side of history what mostly
concerns me is whether I make a mistake
when I'm talking and so I I'm not
thinking about the wrong side of history
precisely so I might be making mistakes
that concerns me all the time but I
thought most I thought the things that I
say through very carefully and you know
I'm perfectly willing to live or die by
them let's say so well I ask you that
because you know we've gone through a
litany of you know using people's
preferred pronouns of the idea of
compassion neither of which do you
support and we've gone through things
like Alex Jones and extremists and
social media and these are ideas that
you wonder if you constantly finding
yourself defending just bad like bad
people and even if you're not one if you
mostly what I find myself doing is being
supported by a very large number
people and being what would you call put
on the spot in various uncomfortable
ways by a tiny noisy minority of radical
collectivists that's mostly what I feel
or mostly what I experience so history
isn't your buddy sure you know who says
sacks don't care about your feelings so
if you that's how you feel I'm sorry
that's not my intent here but again that
is self authoring calm 12 rules for life
dr. Jordan Peterson thanks for taking
the time you know I listen man I mean
you have you have your point of view and
I have mine and I mean there it is hey
if you like this video subscribe but
that doesn't really mean a whole lot so
you can hit the notification bell I know
that Skyler was incredibly unpleasant
with dr. Jordan Peterson I wanted to
kick his ass so I get it
subscribe but the notification Bell join
my club or watch one of these other
videos that could be playing in a box
somewhere maybe YouTube's banded at this
point who knows who knows